foreign
[Music]
data flows or unique features help
execute your job quickly and efficiently
in that episode we showed you how to
troubleshoot streaming jobs that weren't
scaling down but what about data flow
jobs that don't scale up to the max
number of workers stick around to find
out
let's get started
data flow jobs are not scaling up to the
max number of workers despite there
being a demand for more workers
this typically happens if the quota
limits have been reached for your batch
or streaming jobs
be aware developers often run into
machine and network constraints set by
the parent project
so you'll want to ensure the resources
you request are within the applicable
quota limits when running jobs
let's see what this looks like in the
console in the Google Cloud console go
to the data flow jobs page
and click on your data flow job
go to your Matrix tab
and check out the data freshness
if it is not increasing or rather
dropping the job is in a good state in
our project the date of restaurants is
increasing this indicates that the
pipeline is not able to keep up with the
input for streaming jobs navigate to the
auto scaling tab
and compare the current workers to the
Target workers in the auto scaling graph
if the target workers are more than the
current workers it means the job has a
recommendation to scale up
the backlog has to be above 15 seconds
for the upscaling to happen
in our case the backlog is more than two
minutes
check out the CPU utilization graph
the average CPU utilization of the
workers is above 20 percent
actually it is nearly 100 percent
this is a clear signal the data flow
jobs are not scaling up
as mentioned earlier this could be
caused due to exceeding the quota
so let's check the quota
be aware there are multiple types of
codas like number of VMS instances CPUs
or the internal IP addresses let's check
one by one
first let's check the VM instances coda
navigate to the IM admin
quota's page
and apply the filters for
service equals compute engine API
and codas equal
VM instances
you can see in our case the complete
quota for Europe Central 2 region is
occupied keep in mind there is a limited
number of virtual machines you can
create in a region
if other jobs have started many virtual
machines in the same region this could
be draining the project skoda and in
turn your data flow job cannot further
scale up let's check if there are any
code errors on the project level from
The Matrix Explorer
go to the monitoring
Matrix Explorer and put the filters for
metric type equals
a location quota usage
this is another way to monitor your
usage you can see that for the instances
in Europe Central 2 the usage is 240.
similarly if there are any code errors
you'll see the quota exceeded error
under consumer quota
in our project you can see the error
compute engine instance quota is
exceeded this means that our data flow
job has exceeded the VM instances quota
which is causing the workers not to
scale further up to address this issue
you can either free up the virtual
machines or request an increase in the
Project's virtual machine quota
other quota types that may be affecting
your job include the number of virtual
CPUs
since workers may be using more than one
virtual CPU
alternatively if the job is consuming
the service over the internet you might
be running out of the IP addresses quota
freeing up these resources or requesting
a quota increase should help alleviate
the situation
check out this documentation to learn
more about the quota increase process
to learn more about troubleshooting Auto
scaling issues in data flow check out
this documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]